- So I thought we would start
with something a little different, a joke.
A senior civil servant
was asked a question,
"How do you define cloud governance?"
They thought for a moment and responded,
"It's when we move our
servers to the cloud.
We also bring along our
500 page policy documents
on our flights."
It's governance in the cloud.
So, we do have a lot to
share with you today.
We are going to be spotlighting
a major public sector organization,
Japan's Digital Agency.
The agency serves its citizens
by spearheading the digital transformation
of its national ministries
and local governments.
My name is Nivas Durairaj.
I'm part of our cloud
governance team here at AWS
and we help our customers
with building out foundations on AWS.
We're joined by Mr. Ohmura,
who is the specialist SA manager in Japan,
and he leads cloud operations
and cloud governance.
And our special guest
speaker, Mr. Yamamoto,
who is the Chief Cloud Officer
at the Digital Agency of Japan.
Okay.
Here's our agenda.
We're gonna first talk
about what does it mean
to balance agility and compliance
and why is it important for organizations?
Then the core part of this presentation,
the governance story of the
Digital Agency of Japan.
And lastly, we'll round it off
with a few key governance launch updates.
Let's talk about customer needs
in highly regulated industries.
Here are a few key needs
that customers in this space have.
And usually the customers
are customers in healthcare,
public sector and financial services.
But it's really any
customer that's dealing
with sensitive data sets
as well as workloads
with strict security and
compliance requirements.
So if you look at innovation, here,
we're discussing teams that
are expanding on the cloud.
They're building new products,
and they need to take advantage
of some of our latest tooling,
some of the latest AI services.
They wanna bring the products to market
as quickly as possible.
With regenerative AI and gen AI,
it's really time for organizations
to rethink existing processes
and see how we can build
some automation with AI.
But if application teams are doing this,
then the central operations teams
will also have to think
about how to expand
the cloud environment and how
to do it efficiently at scale.
Organizational agility, this simply refers
to the ability of an
organization to adapt to change
as well as deliver outcomes
without unnecessary friction,
essentially reducing roadblocks
for the organization.
And of course our security
and compliance teams
are looking to make sure
that the organization adheres
to the security compliance
regulation policies
and standards and frameworks.
So, we can actually place these needs
into two separate areas,
agility and compliance.
Your development teams are
looking for the independence
to make technical decisions on their own.
They also want the freedom to experiment
and build products.
On the other side, your
central operations teams
are looking to see how
they can build efficiency
and standardization at scale
across the entire organization.
And then of course, your security teams
are looking to implement controls
to make sure that the organization
is following regulatory and
compliance requirements.
So there's a tension here.
It almost seems like this is
moving in opposing directions.
And so the key insight here
is that this isn't an
either or proposition.
It's actually a balanced approach.
We need both agility and
compliance within an organization.
You will see that guardrails
replace the roadblocks.
We're simply defining clear boundaries
on where teams can operate,
and then automation enables compliance.
And the last one is it's
a shared security model.
Everybody is responsible
for security and compliance.
So we talked a little
about cloud governance
at the beginning and that
was the incorrect definition,
but what's the real definition?
And here at AWS, we actually
have a formal definition
for cloud governance.
It's a set of rules, processes,
and reports that guide your organization
to follow best practices,
essentially building your
foundation in alignment
with the business requirements
of the organization.
So it's great to have a
definition, but where do we begin?
And so oftentimes,
this starts by building
an environment on AWS.
A great analogy to think of it as a house,
the same design principles
when you're building a house,
determining where the rooms
go, the access points,
the doors, very similar.
You'll be building an AWS
environment like this.
We build our environment on AWS
using two foundational services,
AWS organizations and AWS Control Tower.
This diagram here, that is
an architectural diagram,
a multi account environment.
It's what AWS Control
Tower deploys for you.
And we are highlighting it here
because it follows the
well architected principles
in building your foundations.
And we'll talk about a few of them.
And landing zone, it
simply means a secure,
scalable multi account environment.
And if you look at this diagram here,
notice the multiple accounts.
This is actually a very key principle
on how we design our services.
We use multiple accounts
because it helps us operate efficiently,
it helps us manage our
teams, and at the same time,
it reduces risk, security risks,
reducing the security blast radius.
And then if you look at this diagram,
notice that it sets up Identity Center.
One of the very first steps
that a lot of our customers take
is that they set up identity access
to the multiple accounts.
And in this case, Identity
Center is integrated
or can be integrated with Okta, Ping,
any kind of identity federation provider.
The next is the log archive account.
This is based on the principle
that we want to track activity
that's taking place
across your environment.
And so in this case, Control
Tower is centralizing
CloudTrail logs across its environment,
and it's also including AWS Config logs.
So we are tracking the API activity
as well as resource configuration changes
that are important for compliance
as well as operational investigations.
Next is the audit account.
You can also think of it
as the security account.
Here lies all of our security
administrative tools.
And in Control Tower's case,
it sets up the AWS Config aggregator.
We'll hear a little bit more
about Config in a future slide,
but the takeaway here
is that you can receive
security notifications
on non-compliant resources
across your environment.
Now, provisioning accounts,
I guess I wanna be clear
that when we create accounts,
it's quite simple to create an account,
but when you provision an account,
there's actually a lot more steps
that take place in
provisioning an account.
We are actually customizing the account
so that it can be used by other teams.
Typically what happens
is customers will set up
the proper networking
resources, identity security,
lots of administrative tools,
and in some cases, they may also set up,
depending on who is using those accounts,
domain specific tools could be SageMaker
or could be database tools and so on.
So that's what it means
to provision accounts.
We provide some customizations
frameworks to do this,
but it's important to understand
that sometimes provisioning
accounts can get complicated
and can take some time.
It's different from account creation.
Lastly, it's the QR code at the edge.
It guides you on how to create some OUs
within your environment.
You don't have to create every single OU,
but the principle to take away here
is that create OUs based
on common policy groupings.
So this summarizes our
environment best practices.
Use accounts as building blocks,
the multi account environment,
automate the account
provisioning and customization,
track activity across your environment
and implement a strong
identity federation.
Okay, so landing zone governance,
we talked about the landing zone,
we talked about centralizing
identity access and logging,
automating, account provisioning.
But there's something that's missing,
something very important,
and important for security and compliance.
It's establishing controls.
So the three types of
governance controls, preventive.
And here, we're simply making
sure that users and roles
are restricted from performing
actions on resources.
And this applies across
the CLI and console.
And then with proactive controls,
we're scanning the resources
before they're provisioned.
And this can take place
with infrastructures code
and sometimes developer pipelines.
The benefit of proactive
controls is that this leads
to developer development
efficiency along the same lines
of shifting left principles,
but we're catching the errors
before it gets provisioned or deployed.
And then the last advantage
of proactive controls too
is also about the cost efficiency.
We're preventing the
resources from being deployed,
so that results in lower costs.
Then the last one is detective controls.
These are simply non-blocking
rules, but we'll tell you,
we'll evaluate certain resources
and tell you what's
compliant or non-compliant.
So AWS organizations has
three preventive controls.
Two of them launched last year,
resource control policies
and declarative policies.
With service control policies,
we are preventing or
restricting identities
based on API actions.
And I'm sure everyone's
quite familiar with them,
they've been around for several years,
but you can apply them to
all of our AWS resources,
containers, EC2, SageMaker and so on.
Now, RCPs, resource control policies,
define the maximum available
permissions on a resource.
So we typically see this being used
for data perimeter use cases,
and it's very helpful
when we are able to apply
what permissions can be
enabled on a service at scale
across a multi account organization.
And so the services that
it supports today are S3,
KMS and Secrets Manager.
But very powerful when
you don't have to think
about what permissions should be allotted
to each and every resource
in your organization.
And then declarative policies
are also very powerful.
Here, they enforce a desired
configuration for a resource,
and those resources
include VPC, EC2 and EBS.
But again, the power here is
that this is applied at scale.
Now, AWS Config rules, these
are our detective controls.
I think the main points I'd
like you to take away from here
is we can group Config rules
into conformance packs,
and that makes it easier to
deploy across the organization,
maintain the Config rules as
well as view them centrally
in a dashboard.
So that's the benefit of
using conformance packs.
And then Config also supports aggregators.
In Control Tower, you
notice that we had set up
a Config aggregator in
the security account,
but you can also create
custom Config aggregators
for your own special accounts or regions.
And then custom rules.
You can build custom rules
depending on what your
business requirements are.
And almost every single customer
will want to create custom rules.
And the easiest way to
create custom rules today
is using Kiro or Amazon Q Developer.
It used to be a lot more complicated.
We did have some frameworks earlier,
but now it's far easier to create it
with some of our gen AI tooling.
So the question is,
should we start by building custom rules?
You certainly could,
but we would recommend
that you also take a look
at our managed controls,
and we have a number of managed controls
across our services.
AWS Control Tower has
over 1000 control types
as well as 17 frameworks,
so you can search through
these common controls
and understand how to apply them at scale
across your multi account environment.
And that's a big benefit of
using Control Tower controls.
It doesn't just apply to one account,
it applies to all of the accounts
that are under Control Tower governance.
And then we also have Security Hub CSPM,
and this checks to confirm
if an AWS environment
is following security best practices.
It centralizes the findings
across all of your accounts,
and you can also integrate it
with third party security tools.
So here we have two separate AWS services
with managed controls.
The question that often
our customers ask is,
how do we know which service
is applying which control
and why are these controls being used?
And so that's why we have
the controls catalog,
which is also part of
AWS Control Tower today.
But it lets you search,
list out your controls
across your environment,
understand the control
objectives, for example,
whether we are using it for a
control for data encryption,
lets you search which kinds
of controls are applied
to different services and so on like that.
So you don't even have to
enable AWS Control Tower
to search through the catalog.
You can simply visit the catalog
and list out the managed controls there.
So here are the controls best practices.
Align your control objectives
to a security framework.
Apply the detective controls
before the preventive controls.
And this is a very important
one because far too often,
we see that customers are impacted
by applying preventive controls.
And while it might seem like
there will be no impact,
it has impacted production workloads.
So the guidance here is
try as much as possible
to apply detective controls,
understand what is non-compliant
before applying preventive controls.
And then of course the last
one is continuously monitor
and test your controls.
Your development teams are always building
and using new tools.
We want our controls to adapt
to what your teams are
doing in the organization.
So the question is,
I talked a lot about AWS
cloud governance principles
and we covered a little bit
of information on services,
but how does this look like
in a real world scenario?
How do you implement
governance defined by law,
and where does a large
organization even begin?
The Digital Agency of Japan
supports 1,700 plus local governments,
and has an environment
of 6,000 plus accounts.
Here's a short video
introducing the agency.
- [Narrator] You can't
see digital technology,
but it's always there right beside you.
(birds chirping)
(indistinct chattering)
And there are things only
Digital can make possible.
With Digital, you can get
the certificates you need
without worrying about having enough time.
(cheerful music)
Payments are made simpler and easier
by using your My Number Card.
(cheerful music)
At school, everyone can
learn at their own pace
using personalized
textbooks or digital tools.
(cheerful music)
Your identity can be
verified securely at events.
(cheerful music)
Even when you're busy
caring for your child,
you can submit applications
without visiting public office.
(cheerful music)
Even if a patient cannot speak,
their medical history and prescriptions
can be shared immediately.
Anytime, anywhere.
The right service for the right
person at the right moment.
By providing personalized support for all,
we strive to build an inclusive society
accessible to everyone.
Digitalization for
everyone in everyday life.
Digital Agency.
- Okay.
Okay, hi everyone.
Can you hear me?
Okay, good.
I'm Nori Yamamoto, Chief Cloud Officer
of Digital Agency in Japan.
I'd like to talk about how
we achieved both scalability
and governance in our Government
Cloud project in Japan.
First of all, let me introduce
Digital Agency itself.
Digital agency was founded
in September, 2020,
just after the COVID-19 worldwide shock.
During the COVID-19, we Japanese noticed
that we could not trace
who was vaccinated or not,
where the vaccines are
available or in short
because of the paper
and manual operations.
At that time, one of the
minister referred to it
as a digital defeat.
To solve this situation,
Digital Agency was founded
and has been driving the
digital transformation
of the government over past four years.
We achieved many things.
For example, the My Number Card.
You saw the My Number Card in the videos,
and the My Number Card is
a national ID card in Japan
and which are possessed
by 100 million people,
almost 80% of the population in Japan.
Recently, there's some
personal information
like medical information
or tax information,
those information are integrated
into the My Number Card
and My Number portal.
So we can access to
the digital application
by using the My Number Card.
The Government Cloud.
The Government Cloud is a baseline
for those digital transformation
or digital applications.
And many systems are start
using the Government Cloud
as their common platform,
the common platform for
the digital transformation.
Not only the central government
ministries and agencies,
but also the local governments.
We actually, we have
1,700 local governments
and quasi-public organizations.
Now we have more than 6,000 AWS accounts
and 300 to 400 accounts
that created in every month recently.
It's scaling very fast.
To create 300 AWS accounts in one month,
the account provisioning must be automated
that we've developed
such kind of automation,
not me exactly, the (indistinct),
and any other members develop it.
And before the automation,
the users who are in the
queue of the account creation
and have to wait for that
completion for five working days.
But after the automation,
the users can start using
cloud in the next day.
And a reduction in our
administrative tasks.
Those are very significant, also.
Before the automation,
the creating accounts took 30 minutes
and some preparatory tasks
related to several accounts
take one hour or so.
So the creating the 300
AWS accounts in one month,
it used to take 260 person hour,
but after the automation,
we reduce it to zero, zero.
So that's the results
of our scalability mechanism we developed.
And before explaining
our scalable mechanism,
we government officers
must emphasize this,
the governance is also very important.
And for the local governments,
the independence of the local governments,
local autonomy, is also very crucial.
And the governance and the
local autonomy and scalability,
those are kinds of contradiction I think.
So the government card must
be the balanced platform
that resolves the conflict
between the governance,
local gov, local autonomy and scalability,
enabling all these achieved.
So again, the governance and
local autonomy and scalability,
those are government card objectives.
I explain three objectives
and how we achieved we three
by balancing all of them.
But before explaining three objectives,
let me explain the system
overview of the Government Cloud.
The users can access
to their own cloud environment directory
and the management functions
and logs functions are set up
aside the cloud environment,
the user cloud environment
by using the cloud service cloud services
like Control Tower or Security
Hub as Nivas mentioned.
And then the GCAS, Government
Cloud Assistance Services,
which is the web services we developed
that's so-called the vending machine.
And also the visualizing dashboard
or payment management systems.
Those are developed outside
the management functions
of the Government Cloud
by connecting loosely.
So to achieve the agility and scalability,
we have to avoid creating the bottlenecks
like (indistinct),
integrated management systems
over top over the cloud.
Instead we enable users
to leverage the cloud technology directly
so the users can use the Government Clouds
just as they would the public cloud.
Then the first objective, the governance.
I explain two aspects of the governance.
The one is institutional aspect
and the other is the technical aspect.
The first one is institutional aspect
Data are encrypted and
under the direct contract
between Japanese government and the CSPs.
The direct contract is very important
for claiming the sovereign immunity.
The direct contract is
under the Japanese law.
And strong data domestically
is very important
for ensuring that laws effect directory.
And selling the data domestically
and data appropriately to
ensure those kind of things.
The audit and the contract certification
called ISMAP in Japan,
those are very important.
To summarize, I'm sorry, to summarize,
data are managed domestically
and it's under the direct contract
based on the Japanese law.
We can ensure those are
operated appropriately
according to the audit and certification.
So that's how we achieved
the institutional aspect
of the governance.
And second, the technical
aspect of the governance.
Data are encrypted by the
user's own encryption key.
The encryption key is stored in HSN
and hardware security module,
which is the certified
as the (indistinct) 140.
The encryption key is
authorized to be managed
by the key owner in the
key management services.
So to access the encryption key,
key owner is strictly
identified by My Number
and it is strongly authenticated
by (indistinct) devices.
So nobody can access to data
directly bypassing encryption.
And technically the
data is fully controlled
by the key owner only.
Therefore, the data are
governed both institutionally
through contract and law and technically
through encryption and
strict key management.
Those kind of governance approach
doesn't impact the scaling
because there are no bottlenecks
for the user application
except encryption.
The users just encrypt data.
Then the second
objectives, local autonomy.
So as I mentioned before,
the local government
emphasize the local autonomy,
local autonomy, independence,
their independence.
So, only pre predefined automated process
can access to environment,
and even Digital Agency
employees must not to access
to the environment of
the local government.
And when Digital Agency employees access
to management accounts,
management functions,
the predefined procedures are required.
And those kind of
procedures and operations
are reviewed by the auditor every year.
So the user, of course data encrypted
and even the data agency
employees cannot access
to data directory bypassing encryption.
So, the user can control the data
in the independent environment
from CSP and data agency.
And those kind of local autonomy approach
doesn't impact scaling also.
And the third objectives,
agility and scalability.
As I mentioned before,
the agility and scalability
is almost realized
by the cloud technology
like Control Tower.
But it's still necessary
to map the real structure
to AWS organizations
because the real structure,
the organizational structure,
power structure which is define
who is responsible for what,
does define one organization to another.
So the AWS organization's
service is not enough
to represent the real
organizational structure.
Rather than that, I think AWS
organizations must be designed
according to AWS best practices
like SGP policies, et cetera.
So we need to develop
the mapping functions
between the real structure
to AWS organizations,
and we have to develop
the management system
of mapping information.
Then we developed automated
such kind of process
during the provisioning.
That caused the results of
our scalability mechanisms
as I mentioned before, the
waiting time reduction,
the task reduction.
Sorry.
And we, sorry.
And we developed these three objectives
over five GSPs we contracted.
So multiple cloud strategy
is very important, I think.
We defined some rules as
our multiple cloud strategy.
For example, the first one
is one CSP for one system.
Do not split a single cohesive system
into multiple clouds.
even if they would like to conduct,
they would like to build
the redundant system
across the clouds.
They can build the redundant
system even in one CSP
by using the multiple regions,
a multiple availability zone.
If they split the systems,
one system into the one (indistinct),
it leads to cost increase
and the complex operations, I think.
The second one is similar to the first one
and necessary for integrated
management systems.
I think one operational organization,
one operational team
should deal with one CSP
because when they want
to deal with two class,
they have to acquire skills double
and they have to pile
up the knowledge double.
So those leads to cost increase
and complex operations.
And last thing is data portability.
Data portability is also
important, of course.
And the data and the programs,
especially related to
the core application,
those should be exported and the data
and the programs portability
is very important.
For example, the (indistinct) technology
rather than lambda function as a services.
Those would be preferred,
especially for the core applications.
And in the final deck,
we are planning the additional services
around the existing ones
to assist the cloud usage,
total cloud usage from
the fast registration
to the operations.
For example, we will release git services,
we call it GCAS DevStack in April, 2026.
And regarding AI, we've been
prepared AI environments
where the user can utilize AI services.
And Japan has announced
the government policy
to actively utilize AI,
and we will prepare for the government AI.
So the AI services in government
card will be the platform,
will be the infrastructure
for government AI.
So we are continuously contributing to it.
So, those are how we
achieved three objectives
of the Government Cloud and how
we achieved both scalability
and governance in our
Government Cloud projects.
So I introduce Ohmura.
Ohmura will explain
(indistinct) in more detail.
Ohmura, please.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much, Yamamoto,
for sharing variable experience
at Government Cloud in Japan.
Hi, I'm Yutaka Ohmura,
manager of specialist
solution architects in Japan.
I worked with Digital
Agency to build the agility
and governance in the Government Cloud.
As we discussed Digital Agency's case<
a key point of their success
was the implementation
of best of practices for cloud
government, cloud governance.
Nivas already shared several
best of practice with us,
and I pick out four best of practice
and I will dive deep into
these best practices.
And let's learn the lesson
from Digital Agency.
First best practice is
align control objectives
to a security framework.
How achieve this in Digital relationship?
For governance, as Yamamota
explained, start with the law
and finally it's implemented at the end.
Digital Agency aligns with
principle based approach,
so a high level document like law
and regulation defines a guideline.
And each organizations and
systems needs to determine
and define their own controls
following that guidance.
As you can see on top,
in Japan we have a law,
the basic act on cybersecurity.
And for the regulation,
national cybersecurity office
defined unified standards
for information security
measures for government agencies.
And Digital Agency created a guideline,
a security by design guideline
for government information system.
These guidelines are
not so specific enough,
So they difference the
framework like Nist CSF
and control catalogs like NIST SP800-53.
With this framework and control catalog,
they mapped their guidelines
to implementation.
And here is another control objectives,
ensure proper security measures
without disrupting operational efficiency.
To achieve this, they use
these two types of controls.
First one is preventative control.
They are using AWS organizations
service control policy.
But they use this in minimum
because they don't want to
limit the developer function.
For example, prevent users
from creating IM user
and access key.
That's a preventative control.
And they mainly rely on
to detective controls.
They're using AWS Security Hub CSPM.
For the detective controls, for example,
AWS Config should be enabled and so on.
To implement that, they
using AWS security hub,
CSP'S standard like CIS benchmark
and the AWS foundational
security best practices.
Security hub already have managed control
and mapping to framework
so they can easily
implement control objective.
This is how they created the controls.
Moving to next topic,
the second best practice
is to implement strong
identity foundation.
As Yamamota mentioned,
they're managing several
thousands of users,
local government and its users.
So, automation and
scalability are the keys.
First challenge is the
five days to create users.
That's because they had
a manual user process,
manual user authentication process.
So they created all authentication systems
to use My Number Card.
As Yamamota said, its an
Japan's national ID card.
So they implement it on GCAS.
GCAS is Government Cloud
Assistance Systems they created.
And on top of that,
they implement that user
authentication systems.
With this automated system,
they reduced the lead
time of user creation
from five days to just one hour,
and also reduced the
workload of Digital Agency.
Second challenge is thousands of users
on IAM Identity Center.
There is a limitation of permissions,
number of permission sets
in IAM Identity Center.
That's 3,500.
To scale that,
they created the idea
just two permission sets,
administrator and non-administrative.
For administrator,
they associate it with the
administrator permission set.
With that permission set,
when user creates the account,
the administrator role will recreate it.
With this role, they
can create another role.
They don't use IAM users
because this agency
not permit to create IM users.
So instead of that, they
create laws on guest account
To use such a law,
they use non administrator law.
This the non administrator user.
This user is associated
with the permission set
for Switch role only role.
With this law, non-administrator user
can switch the other roles
like developer roles and operator roles.
With this simple model,
they can easily scale user management
and keep it simple to manage users.
The third best of practice
is automate account
provisioning and customization.
Yamamoto said they create
370 accounts per month.
So they need to automate everything.
They're using multiple
cloud service provider.
So when user want to create account,
they have access to the data fast.
And from GCAS, it's kick
the step functions workflow
and sends the request and
store the request to the SQS.
Then Lambda function create
account with Control Tower.
This SQS is needed to
limit the account creation,
parallel account creation
because Control Tower
limits account creation
to five at once.
Then they call several
APIs with lambda function,
or for example subscribe to
enterprise support and so on.
As you may know, Control Tower
have account customization
with infrastructure code
like Cloud Formation.
However, infrastructure's code is suitable
for define the status.
So instead of that, to
define the procedure
lambda level function is suitable.
And especially subscribed
to enterprise support
is not supported by cloud permission.
So in such case, the lambda
function is suitable.
And also they have
another database on GCAS.
This is because this is real world.
So when user want to create account,
Digital Agency needs to have
some real world information
like local government name
or email address for billing.
To store this data on GCAS,
they don't need to have manual process
like writing some
information on note or so.
Like this, Digital Agency created
a fully automated
mechanism account creation.
And yeah, this is the automated
one time account setup.
For the resources defined
by infrastructures code
and require changes in the future,
Digital agency uses two
type deployment model
with service catalog.
What is prototype deployment?
They defined secure baseline.
For example, check and remove
default security group,
and so on.
This is defined by CDK,
and they created several service
catalog products from that.
And when local government
administrator want to deploy it,
they pull that product and deploy it.
They own their account by themselves,
then they create their own systems.
These two type deployment
compare to push style deployment.
It's like a CloudFormation
stack and so on.
However, if Digital Agency
uses CloudFormation stack set,
there are two problems.
First one is Digital Agency
is not permitted to access
to the guest account because
of the local autonomy.
This is one problem.
And second problem is if Digital Agency
deploy these baseline
by cloud (indistinct),
they need to coordinate
with the local government administrators.
for example, when the
template will be deployed
or what's the current status
of that secure baseline.
So this prototype deployment model
enabled them this secure baseline
without any coordination by
local government administrator.
And when Digital Agency want
to update the secure baseline,
it's very simple.
Digital Agency should just update
the service catalog product.
Then, a local government administrator
pull that new version of the product
and deploy it by themselves.
There is no coordination
between Digital Agency
and local administrator.
This is a pull style deployment model.
Okay, last best of practice
is continuous monitoring
and testing of controls.
Don't set and forget.
In the government cloud,
local government administrator
has responsibility
to fix security issues.
However, digital agencies administrator
usually don't send security issues
to local government administrator.
So how to notify?
In the secure baseline,
Digital Agency already
defined the event breach rules
and AWS chatbot.
With this services, detected
security issues sent
to the local government
administrator directly
and they fix that security
issues by themselves.
This distributed notification systems
enabled Digital Agency not to handle
a massive number of (indistinct).
because they have thousands of accounts.
Then also enable to align local autonomy.
However, other administrator,
Digital Agency needs to understand
the security posture of
the Government Cloud.
To do that, they get periodic
report from security hub
and check critical event only.
Once they find critical event,
they notify to local
government or administrator.
This is how they implement
to manage security postures at scale.
This conclude AWS cloud
governance best practice
that Digital Agency has
addressed in detail.
So I hand it back Nivas to
wrap up this presentation.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- So you heard from Mr.
Yamamota and Mr. Ohmura
on how the Digital Agency
achieved a real world
implementation of cloud governance
and had real impact.
And this is just a summary
of the best practices.
So feel free to take a picture.
We covered it all in our sessions.
And now the launch updates,
we had several and we just decided
to point a few of the key
ones, namely transfer accounts.
A lot of organizations are moving accounts
between different organizations
for mergers and acquisitions
or just different business needs.
And in the past, we had to
make an account standalone,
add credit card information
and then move it to the
second organization.
Now you can simply invite the account
over to the target organization.
So this makes it much more efficient.
Second launch AWS billing transfer.
While we still recommend
that organizations
use a single organization,
sometimes there are cases
where companies and customers
have to use multiple organizations
due to regulatory compliance
or actual business requirements.
Example, partners that are
supporting multiple customers,
in this case in the past
administrators to log into each
and every management account
of the different organizations
and review the costs, the
cost analysis and invoicing.
Now you can centralize that.
Now you have centralized view
of what's taken across
multiple organizations.
And so this helps with invoice collection,
payment processing and cost analysis.
And something to note here too
about the AWS organizations.
Even though the administrator can review
across different organizations,
each organization is still
responsible for its security.
So this is just sending
costs over, centralizing it,
providing cost visibility,
but the security management
is still separate.
On controls only, we talked
about the controls catalog.
We talked about AWS Control Tower.
Now you can have a
controlled solely experience
with AWS Control Tower.
You don't necessarily need
the landing zone components.
And so this will be very
helpful for customers
that have already built
out a custom landing zone.
They can simply take
advantage of the controls
in Control Tower, which
include SCPs, RCPs,
as well as Config rules to apply at scale.
So as next steps, just
sharing some resources,
I did not share all of our launches,
but this QR code summarizes a list
of our cloud governance
and other launches.
And the key takeaway,
cloud governance gives
you the right foundation
to experiment and execute.
We saw this clearly with
the governance story
of the Digital Agency of Japan.
And thank you very much for
the engagement and support.
And special thanks to Mr. Yamamoto.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)